pues vamos a seguir hablando acerca de
sólidos de revolución y calculando sus
volúmenes pero en esta ocasión me voy a
tomar la función que es igual a la raíz
de x y si ustedes hacen un poco de
memoria su gráfica se ve más o menos así
pueden dibujarla y darse cuenta que esta
es la gráfica de que es igual a la raíz
de x a la raíz positiva de x ahora esto
no va a acabar aquí también me voy a
tomar otra función en este problema en
este problema vamos a considerar también
la función que es igual a x la función
identidad y por qué porque ahora lo que
voy a querer hacer es girar estas dos
funciones y calcular el volumen del
sólido de revolución que me queda entre
estas dos funciones es decir lo que voy
a querer calcular es el volumen del
sólido de revolución que me va a quedar
al girar el área que está encerrada
entre estas dos gráficas alrededor del
eje de las x suena interesante no ahora
vamos a empezar con la intuición
imagínate que aquí voy a dibujar a la
función y es igual a la raíz de x pero
esta vez girada alrededor del eje de las
x por lo tanto que es lo que me va a
quedar
y esto me va a servir para que lo
visualicemos mejor entonces este punto
se va a conectar con este punto y esta
va a ser la parte exterior del sólido de
revolución que en esta ocasión quiero
calcular esta parte va a ser la exterior
es decir este tazón o este trofeo no sé
cómo llamarlo llamémoslo trofeo entonces
este trofeo va a ser la parte exterior
la cara exterior de este sólido de
revolución mientras que por otra parte
yo tengo la función y es igual a x por
lo tanto adentro de este trofeo yo tengo
un cono imagínense que yo giro la
función que es igual a x alrededor de
elegirlas xy por lo tanto me va a quedar
un cierto cono
vamos a intentar darle un poco más de
proporción y esta es la parte interna de
mi sólido de revolución que yo voy a
creer o dicho de otra manera vamos a
tratar de dibujar alguna de sus paredes
imagínense que esta va a ser mi pared
esta de aquí es una de mis paredes de mi
sólido de revolución claro del sólido de
revolución que en esta ocasión quiero es
decir esta área que yo tengo aquí es la
que voy a girar alrededor del eje de las
x y por lo tanto me va a salir un sólido
de revolución
el cual voy a querer calcular su volumen
esta es la pregunta en esta ocasión cómo
voy a poder calcular este volumen y ya
estoy viendo tu cara de emoción porque
ya te estás imaginando cómo vamos a
resolver este problema la idea que hay
detrás es la siguiente lo que voy a
hacer es calcular el volumen del sólido
de revolución que está en la función y
es igual a la raíz de x ya esto le voy a
quitar el volumen del sólido de
revolución que me queda al tirar la
función que es igual a x por lo tanto
vamos a hacerlo para esto voy a utilizar
también el método de los discos que
hemos venido utilizando en los vídeos
anteriores la idea es la siguiente
primero me voy a agarrar un disco este
disco que tengo yo aquí en la función y
es igual a la raíz de x entonces vamos a
ponerlo con un color que se vea mejor
este va a ser mi radio de mi disco esta
es la cara de la moneda o del disco y
también teníamos un cierto grosor este
va a ser mi grosor que en este caso era
de x recuerdan este es mi grosor de x y
por lo tanto siguiendo esta idea lo
primero que voy a hacer es calcular el
volumen de este disco qué es
el ancho es decir de x que multiplica al
área de este círculo es decir pi por
radio al cuadrado pi por radio pero en
este caso el radio es igual a la función
y la función es igual a la raíz de x
elevada al cuadrado por lo tanto me
queda pi que multiplica al radio elevado
al cuadrado pero en esta ocasión el
radio es igual a la raíz de x y por lo
tanto me queda pi que multiplica la raíz
de x elevado al cuadrado de x y entonces
lo que yo hacía era tomar la suma de
todos estos discos que construía
alrededor del eje de las x por lo tanto
me tomaba yo la integral recuerden que
lo que estaba pensando era tomarme la
suma de todos estos discos y después el
límite haciendo que estos discos fueran
muy pero muy delgados y entonces
acuérdense que el resultado resumido de
toda esta idea se llamaba la integral
entonces me tomaba la integral de esta
expresión y ahora qué es lo que nos
faltan lo que nos faltan son los límites
de integración entre que el límite y que
el límite de integración me estoy
tomando y para esto lo que necesito es
encontrar los puntos de intersección
entre estas dos curvas es decir en qué
momento estas dos curvas son iguales lo
que voy a querer es que
x sea igual a la raíz de x pero para
resolver esta igualdad lo que voy a
hacer es pasar la raíz cuadrada del otro
lado es decir me queda que x cuadrada
es igual a equis y para qué valores se
cumple esto bueno si hacemos un poco de
memoria hay dos valores para los que se
cumple esto mi primer valor es x igual a
0 que bueno ya lo sabíamos en este punto
que teníamos aquí en mi segundo valores
cuando x vale 1 porque 1 al cuadrado es
lo mismo que 1 por lo tanto ya tengo mis
dos valores o si lo queremos ver de una
manera más formal me quedaría que x
cuadrada menos x es igual a 0 o dicho de
otra manera lo que tenemos que hacer es
resolver una ecuación de segundo grado y
para esto lo que voy a hacer es
factorizar a una x es decir x que
multiplica a x menos 1 tiene que ser
igual a 0 y esto tiene dos soluciones o
x es igual a 0 o x menos 1 es igual a 0
y entonces se tienen dos soluciones o x
es igual a 0 o x es igual a 1 es
importante recordar que dos cosas son
iguales a cero si una es cero o la otra
en cero y por lo tanto ya tengo los
límites de integración de 0 a 1 de esta
expresión y por la raíz de x elevado al
cuadrado
el diferencial de x para calcular el
volumen del sólido de revolución que me
queda al girar la función y es igual a
la raíz de x cuando gira alrededor del
eje de las equis y bueno ahora viene la
sorpresa de este vídeo la sorpresa este
vídeo era que el volumen que nosotros
queremos es la diferencia de los
volúmenes de estos dos sólidos de
revolución por lo tanto lo que voy a
buscar ahora es el volumen del sólido de
revolución que me queda al girar la
función 10 igual a x alrededor del eje
de las x voy a tomarme un disco adentro
de esta función y me voy a tomar su
volumen entonces su volumen es pi por la
función elevada al cuadrado recuerden
que el radio es lo mismo que la función
que en este caso la función es y es
igual a equis
por lo tanto adentro va x todo esto
elevado al cuadrado ya esto lo tenemos
que multiplicar por el grosor pero el
grosor como estamos haciendo la integral
también alrededor del eje de las x en
este caso también es de x miren aquí
estoy dibujando el grosor es claro que
tengo una moneda aquí por lo tanto voy a
multiplicar por el grosor el cual
habíamos dicho que era de x y recuerden
que con la integral me estoy tomando la
suma y además el límite cuando de x
muy pequeño pues ya cuando estas dos
integrales tenemos las expresiones de
los volúmenes que nosotros queríamos y
la diferencia de estos dos volúmenes es
el volumen que yo busco es decir el
volumen que está entre el trofeo y este
cono raro por lo tanto lo primero que
voy a hacer es resolver estas dos
integrales fíjense que pi puede salir de
la integral por lo tanto de la primera
integral voy a sacar a pi y me queda pi
que multiplica a la integral de 01 de
raíz de x elevado al cuadrado es decir x
de x menos aquí también voy a sacar a pi
que multiplica a la integral de 0 a 1 de
x elevado al cuadrado diferencial de x y
bueno estas integrales ya son muy
fáciles de resolver esto me va a quedar
lo voy a poner aquí
piqué multiplica a quien necesitó el
anti derivada de x que es x cuadrado
entre 2 evaluada de 0 a 1 está muy fácil
esto menos pi que multiplica la anti
derivada de x cuadrada que es x cúbica
entre 3 y esto evaluado de 0 a 1 también
hasta aquí no hay tanto problema después
esto me queda pi que multiplica y en
este paso lo que voy a hacer es la
evaluación voy a substituir a x por uno
y por cero y me queda
un medio menos 0 entre 2 y mejor déjenme
escribirlo así 1 elevado al cuadrado
entre 2 - 0 elevado al cuadrado entre 2
- y aquí tengo pi que multiplica a 1
elevado al cubo entre 3 - 0 elevado al
cubo entre 3 y pues prosigamos primero
voy a seguir teniendo el pie fuera del
paréntesis y me va a quedar esperen
mejor déjenme ponerlo con el mismo color
y que va a multiplicar y 0 entre 2 se va
de una vez lo cancelamos un medio aquí
me queda 1 al cuadrado que es 1 entre
dos pues es lo mismo que un medio y que
multiplica a ti pues es pi medios ya
esto le tengo que quitar y lo mismo 0
entre 3 se va y me queda un tercio que
multiplica a pi y me quedan tercios y
bueno vamos a hacer esto con fracciones
el mínimo común múltiplo de estos 2 6
por lo tanto el común denominador va a
ser 6 y 16 entre 2 es igual a tres por
tres pi entonces me queda 3 y ya esto le
voy a quitar 6 entre 3 estos por fin me
va a quedar
si lo hice bien a ver 6 entre 2 es 3000
multiplica pi 6 entre 32 shift entonces
3 - 2 pies lo mismo que un solo pin me
va a quedar sextos y ya con esto
encontré la solución del volumen de esta
copa extraña que yo estaba buscando y
todo esto gracias al famoso método de
los discos